the street battles have continued
through this weekend despite the Prime
Minister's resignation this is Baghdad
and these are live rounds
the state sanctioned violence against
unarmed protesters is again
extraordinary as it has been most days
over the past month these are young men
born after the tyranny of the Saddam era
now facing government security forces
who are using tactics reminiscent of
that time here protestors again set
alight the Iranian consulate frustrated
not just at political elites running
their country but at their backers too
specifically the regime in Tehran the
number of injured over the past month is
staggering 15,000 people more than 400
are now known to have died all of them
simply calling for their government to
go for the electricity to work for a job
for decent health care basic stuff that
their leaders were unable to provide in
NASA Riya the same the snatched images
filmed by brave local cameramen
paramedics in ambulances do what they
can but mostly it is the protesters
themselves in tuk tuks ferrying the
injured away in a world away the words
of the Prime Minister and the optics too
seemed to prove just how aftertouch the
politicians are in the cabinet meeting
he seemed to suggest that the use of
live rounds had been unintentional and
that his resignation allows the
government to remain strong the
protesters are calling for a transparent
government the protesters want
corruption to disappear the protesters
would like to have opportunities to have
jobs so the protesters will not be
convinced with the appointment of a new
prime minister the protesters would like
actions not just words
not far from the government offices they
were marching this time without any
clashes to honor those who have died
remembered with candles and with their
belongings clothes shoes that they died
in and the helmets which couldn't
protect against live rounds first we
want a country second we want all of
them out no one should stay they are all
feeds the president now has two weeks to
nominate someone to form a new
government but will they listen to the
protesters demands if they don't well
this could become even worse mark stone
Skyler's